hallo mein name ist luca bekommen
endlich wieder seiner folge clever ich
hatte gerade schon wieder eine tolle
unterhaltung mit dem clever wort und
zwar hab ich geschrieben hey darauf er
was ist dein name ich wieder habe er so
ich habe nach seinem namen gefragt ich
wieder heim
und er du hast gerade gesagt du heißt
leon nein mein name ist luca lieber
was für einen dummkopf luca
ausrufezeichen
nein was heißt hier ist ein fluss in
thailand das ist auf jeden fall ein sehr
schöner fluss nein wir starten das ganze
mal wieder von vorn heiratet for
christmas and have to go sie gut das war
es dann mit dem video ich schreib mal
einfach hallo alter freuen wie geht's
dir war hier ist bonn sportfreunde nein
hier ist patrick patrick kannst du nicht
woanders mayonnaise auch ein instrument
ist mal bis auch in strömen ein pr trick
maroni wies kein instrument osterath die
schießenden instrument uwe koßel radisch
meerrettich ist auch kein instrument
locker heißt das horse race of english
und jetzt kommen wir alle an lukas heißt
ich röstaromen es heißt röstaromen
vorher soll ich so was wissen ich bin
bild online ich habe gesehen dass ich
irgendwie wohl auch mal ein mikrofon für
dieses ding hier verwenden kann habe ich
das eigentlich schon mal gemacht hallo
mein name ist luca
kannst du mich gerade gut verstehen er
hat nicht komplett verstanden und sagten
ich solle mich wiederholen ich weiß in
diesem raum halte es noch ein bisschen
aber das ist einfach ich bin von einer
woche oder zwei wochen um stimmt ich hab
eigentlich längst was dran ändern können
wer ist dein lieblings youtuber schreibt
er mir wirklich alter was du siehst du
das thema wir wollen mal das
interessiert mich einfach clever bot ich
würde gerne wissen wer dein lieblings
youtuber ist aber du hast doch gefragt
wie alt ich wen schaust du am liebsten
was ungarisches würdest du eh nicht
verstehen halt doch vielleicht einfach
deine fresse deutsche youtuber punkt was
sind in deutsches sprichwort halt
einfach der mag
sag mir wie schaust du in deutschland
bezüglich youtuber am liebsten so mal
schauen deutsch ist meine muttersprache
mit dieser person kannst du dich einfach
nicht unterhalten ich gebe einfach mal
youtube ein und es kommt call me oder
wilden com macht das nun ok zu naja ich
ja halt doch dein maul deutsch du idiot
dann bin ich halt ein idiot problems
[Musik]
wider so dumm ich weiß tunnel ein call
of duty ja liebe es und gta 5 soll man
dazu sagen ich glaube du bist etwas
anders als wie ich bin tun ich glaube
aber du bist kein mensch
ich frage ihn jetzt mal wenn ich sterben
würde was wären meine letzten worte wenn
du stirbst ich sicher ein blume bastard
ich schreibe es jetzt mal in seinem
deutsch wenn du stirbst und das sagst du
wenn du das was wären deine letzten
worte lieber clever bot warum du keine
kinder mit mir kriegen willst ich will
kinder mit dir ich habe den chat
verlaufen einfach wieder ein bisschen
geklärt damit das ganze ein bisschen
locker bleibt jetzt mich für die letzte
frage weil die schächte ernst ich habe
geputzt riechst du es was heißt das denn
jetzt ob du meinen pups riechst hast du
gar ein dorf gesehen alter mann kann
sich mit dem nicht unterhalten das tut
mir leid dass das ende vom video chat